[Musique]
depuis août dernier le basque est devenu
obligatoire dans toutes les villes de
france pourtant de plus en plus de voix
s'élèvent pour expliquer que le port du
masque à l'extérieur est inutile si son
utilité en interne n'est pas remise en
cause dans la rue le port du masque ne
serait d'aucune utilité pour lutter
contre la propagation de lakovic 19 ans
le masque en extérieur je pense que ça
aura peu d'impact et je pense pas que ce
soit appuyé sur des faits scientifiques
très solide le fait de vouloir l'imposer
par tous d'après le figaro qui publie un
article appuyé sur le professeur de
physique-chimie samra bouazza et le
professeur d'économie serge blondel des
chiffres le prouvent les départements où
le masque a été imposé un extérieur fin
août ont vu leur décès s'accroître de
129 2% contre pile plus 100% dans les
départements périphériques de la région
les régions périphériques qui ont obligé
le port du masque bien plus tard que la
capitale une stratégie qui ne porterait
donc pas ses fruits
c'est ce que pense aussi l'avocat carlo
alberto brusa qui fera face au docteur
dang ben sadoun ce soir merci à carlo
alberto brusa d'être avec nous merci
avocat et c'est vrai que c'est un
personnage incroyable carlo alberto
brusa merci d'être là et dan bensadoun
un médecin qu'on voit beaucoup sur les
plateaux merci d'être là merci de nous
faire l'honneur d'être avec nous dan
merci beaucoup dr ben sadoun et m carlo
alberto brusa alors cette histoire de
masques à l'extérieur hier soir tout le
monde en parlait faut-il donc arrêter de
porter le masque à l'extérieur je vois
qu'ici il n'ya que des noms sauf un oui
du plus jeune d'entre vous guillaume
genton que je comprends non parce que
vous arrivez delphine aussi mes delphine
est serein qu'avec de 82 ans allait
vraiment délire mais c'est vrai que moi
comme ça je vous le dis il est passé
très douce amère je le dis je le dis
devant dan je le dis devant dan qui est
pour bien sûr le port du masque moi
aussi à l'extérieur
je vous dis parfois est-ce qu'il va le
porter ou pas je me pose la question
voilà je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas le
faire mais je me pose la question
oui vous dit marc déjà apporté le mas
toute la journée c'est insupportable
c'est pas confortable j'ai fait une
allergie au delà des problèmes au niveau
de l'épiderme vous le savez cyril
tchèque c'est important suite quand on
est seul dans la rue quand on marche et
que les gens soient un mètre de m 3
mètres j'ai dû marge suis pas du tout
spécialiste mais j'ai du mal à
comprendre en quoi ça représente à
risque de contamination étant donné
qu'on nous parle d'un mètre ou de mer et
puis troisièmement quand on lit la
presse un peu spécialisés avec des
articles avec des spécialistes le
parisien
saman et keita qui disaient même des
gens masqués attrape le virus donc à
quoi ça sert ça pose quand même pas mal
de questions sur la réelle utilité du
masque surtout quand c'est à l'extérieur
alors on va faire des détours des
chroniqueurs pas tous et après bien sûr
on aura nos invités qui vont nous
exposer leur avis ou et kelly pourquoi
pour répondre ce que dit guillaume moi
je pense que tout simplement les
personnes qui l'ont attrapé peut-être
qu'elles sont mal géré leurs masques et
qu'elles l'ont mal utilisé après quand
on se dit que tout simplement
appartement où il ya le moindre risque
est là - et on se pose la moindre
question
eh ben on porte nos masques et on ferme
nos bouches là on a un avocat face à un
médecin j'ai bien envie de savoir quel
est le débat alors assez de monde
attendait là il a étudié le dossier
charles au marché - koné vignoles mais
bien sûr mais je ne le connais pas je me
permets me permettrais pas du tout de le
juger comme un guignol mais à partir du
moment où au moins un médecin parle et
me dit il faut que tu portes on masque
je porte mon match et je me tais c'est
alors justement m carlo alberto brusa
avocat
pourquoi vous pensez vous vous battez
vous avez créé un collectif
voilà qui est de plus en plus rejoint
d'ailleurs où vous dites il faut arrêter
de porter le masque à l'extérieur
notamment dans vos dons je voudrais je
voudrais répondre à votre assistante qui
ferment alors chronique
fermez émission voilà alors d'abord je
m'appelle carlo et pacha renommée je
peux dire à votre chroniqueuse que de
répondre en disant tout simplement si un
médecin m'a dit de porter un masque je
le porte
je me pose pas la question ok ça
s'appelle une approche qu'on appelle
dictatorial aux dictatures solitaire
c'est une manière que qui n'est pas
concevable
parce que quand on parle de pensée
médicale on explique pourquoi quelque
chose on le porte et nous attend que rex
en 19 en tant qu'association nous avons
analysé la problématique des masques
parce qu'il s'agit pas simplement de se
poser la question à l'extérieur est ce
que le masque d'être portés par les
enfants
est-ce que des environs de 6 à 11 ans
dans le panthéon est ce que le match
soit reporté
quand on fait du sport dans les écoles
est ce que le monstre est vraiment utile
pour se protéger du virus alors je
premièrement il n'existe pas d'études
scientifiques
je vous la firme et je vous l'aurais
terre parce que j'ai déposé la plainte
j'ai épluché quasiment toute la
littérature
il n'y a pas d'étude scientifique qui
dit et affirme le port du masque
scientifiquement parlant va vous
protéger du virus d'abord deuxièmement
vous n'avez pas en une quelconque
manifestation juridique sur les masques
qui puisse dire que le masque vous
protège de l'aco vide et je vous mets au
défi de chercher toutes les boîtes sur
le marché moi je disais tout acheter
parce que quand on a déposé la plainte
je voulais pas commettre d'impair et
vous n'avez pas un un une boîte une
comédienne avertissement qui vous dit ah
là là c'est magnifique que vous
éprouviez bien au contraire on dit
attention vous n'êtes pas protégés
contre la copie
alors justement c'est ce que vous direz
alors on va on va voir là la réponse
aussi donne a dit vous allez continuer
votre explosion avoir la réponse de dan
bensadoun sur juste le masque est ce que
c'est ce qu'a dit new marais il protège
pas il ya plein de gens qui nient ce qui
protège pas complètement
c'est parti c'est la dernière partie
sur ce qu'a dit m carlo alberto brusa
qu'est ce que vous avez à lui répondre
il ya plusieurs jeunes ados il ya
plusieurs choses déjà ça n'est pas une
dictature quand un médecin propose
impatient de porter le masque de faire
ceci ou de faire cela le médecin pose
une prescription vous savez très bien
qu'une prescription c'est une
recommandation
quand je fais une prescription à mon
cabinet que je vous donne la
prescription vous en faites ce que vous
voulez vous pouvez aller vous faire ce
que vous voulez avec la feuille la jetée
la mâcher ou mieux l'utiliser même chose
pour le masquer vous savez que le masque
à l'origine est une est un outil médical
que les chirurgiens ont pris pour éviter
justement de contaminer les plaies
qu'ils ouvraient les patients qu'ils
ouvraient savez maintenant est ce que
vous seriez rassurez-vous de savoir que
le chirurgien qui vous a opéré de
l'appendicite des amygdales de ce que
vous voulez ne portait pas de masque est
ce que est ce que vous poseriez des
questions donc je vous remercie beaucoup
enfants et pourtant je suis un bon coup
et pourtant le chirurgien j'évolue sévit
dans ce que vous avez il ne pourra pas
n'est pas porteur de risques énormes
la réalité c'est cette une prescription
médicale c'est la furie du consentement
ça veut dire que je dois avoir le droit
de décider de prendre ou de ne pas
prendre le médicament
donc ce que vous dites c'est pas être
magnifique si on se place et d'une
approche purement médical mais quand
c'est un décret qui maman poser le port
du masque dans lequel je n'ai aucune
explication ni scientifique ni médicale
qui du jour au lendemain a décidé que
les enfants d'abord ne portait pas après
2,6 en un mot le porter et je n'ai pas
d'explication ces dépenses de
prescription c'est une décision
autoritaire ou politique qui a pour
finalité quoi ce que le médecin dit il
faut qu'ils aient un signe extérieur de
viralité
il faut que les gens square participé à
l'immunité
il faut que les gens participent à une
approche culturelle ce sont les propos
de remettre lui-même c'est quelque chose
de scandaleux et l'art ce que vous dites
moi je le partage si c'était une
prescription médicale
je le droit commun comme un vaccin comme
n'importe quel médicament soit je ne
prends soin je ne prends pas alors que
là nous sommes dans une pseudo théorie
de santé publique qui ne tient pas la
route et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui tu as
même des cons qui sont au chaud dans la
voiture avec leur main cela on se
protège enfin c'est ce que j'ai fait
c'est ce que j'ai fait moi
un congrès pour masse dans l'avoine
l'orge ou le dit jeudi m carlo alberto
brusa les chéris alors mégastar innove
par les généraux vous poser une question
quel est l'intérêt aujourd'hui alors
qu'on est en situation et à une
catastrophique où bon an mal an il ya le
vire il ya le gall vaccin mais bon ça va
mettre un peu de temps quel est
l'intérêt aujourd'hui devenir ce
discours à la télévision par rapport aux
masques dont on est quand même content
travaux ce que vous dites que c'est un
des moyens non mais il ya plein de gens
qui disent que le masque à extérieur
alors là dans le sujet regardez pour
devenir effectivement ci ait le moindre
risque y en a un pour cent de risque de
contaminer quelqu'un ou d'attraper le
virus même à l'extérieur pourquoi
dérogeant ne mettait pas qu'elle est qu
est-ce qu aujourd'hui madame monsieur
castaldi
vous avez une situation qui est une
approche d'une sorte de dictature
sanitaire dans lequel le médical est en
train de l'emporter surtout aujourd'hui
vous avez des infos qui sont bâillonnés
qui sont masqués qui ne communiquent
plus vous avez des enquêtes
une allemande qui met en exergue de tous
les problématiques posées
vous avez aujourd'hui des enfants qui se
suicident vous avez la société française
de pédiatrie qui alerté même le
président de république en disant
attention avec la terreur que nous
sommes en train de fermer nos enfants
avec le masque n'a rien avoué d'eux
mêmes sous les masques regarder dans ma
plante vous avez des pièces vous savez
tous les remontées que je mise et dans
les pièces qui ont été déposés vous avez
des maîtres d'école vous avez des
parents qui ont des enfants qui sont
dans un état de détresse mais donc
l'extra que je termine une minute à la
question de l'extérieur moi je ne suis
pas un anti masquer des nantis dax jeudi
que le masque il ya des situations de
kehl alors je suis d'accord avec
d'autres autour de salou paris un
opération chirurgicale nos médecins
n'importe quand on est très proches je
pense que c'est bien moi j'étais même le
premier quand je parle regardez l'italie
ce qui se passait je conseille
d'utiliser même du sopalin parce qu'on
était dans un piteux virale extrêmement
grave important dans les locaux fermés
mais cantonné à l'air libre
c'est la limite il faut s'oxygéner parce
que le problème de l'hypoxie l'hypoxie
est très important à quand j'écoutais
quelqu'un qui est ici que 10 et 15 ans
de maison il me faut trois heures pour
me remettre pour me réussit gêné
l'hypoxie le manque d'oxygène et puis
vous avez aussi l'hyper capli ça veut
dire quand vous avez une augmentation du
co2 dans votre corps quatre masques la
force de risque
avec quelque chose devant vous n'avez
plus cette rotation à prouver que
l'oxygène ça s'est trouvé un celi c'est
à prouver et ponts détruits prouve qu'on
sera dans nos vins français pas du tout
je peux vous dire autre chose de sûre et
nam que ce que je dis je le dis toujours
avec des des sujets ils sont des sujets
pas du tout rédigé par des complotistes
mais par des médecins à titre est
d'accord avec eux vous dit qu'il n'a pas
dit non mais je suis parfois d'accord et
parfois j'allais à l'étranger je suis
nicolas pernikoff mais vous êtes à
l'hypermarché noir démontrer quoi que de
porter un masque est plus dangereux que
de ne pas avoir de masques j'arrive pas
à comprendre votre compte du tout le
portugais de le faire de porter de
masque dans certaines situations oui
mais aujourd'hui traités l'humanité le
peuple français 24 heures sur 24 avec
des masques à l'intérieur à l'extérieur
quand on fait comme on est dans la vie
il ya des matches à l'extérieur
c'est un moment de liberté avec les
masques aujourd'hui jours ont été perdus
mais on est un petit peu un petit peu de
raison dans ce qui se passe en ce moment
vous savez que ce virus est un virus
aéroportée et aussi manu portet donc qui
est véhiculé tout à l'heure vous disiez
qu'il ya des personnes qui ont porté le
masque et qui malheureusement ont
contracté la maladie pourquoi pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont peut-être mal utiliser
le masque mais presque aussi le virus et
manu porteurs du gène nommé pour 100 g
la section 1900 à part les mains et
facebook aujourd'hui les deux manuportée
pourquoi mais il compare les mains mais
après yves ils vont où vos mains elles
vont dans vos nez dans vos orifices
naseaux au niveau des rues fils ben
coudonc la transmission se fait par les
muqueuses avec le touch en plus mais
quand vous touchez le masque non mais on
ne change pas et qu'effectivement le
porto la journée non mais la dévier les
recommandations vous le connaissez très
bien la langue dation de l'autoriser de
rambouillet vous savez qu'on pose des
règles pour le port du masque et aux
communistes ne respecte pas venu
flotteurs ne voit enlever les poser et
les remettre nos moments cantonales m
masque on le fait quand le jeu direct on
échoue le jette joop poubelles et nos
moments il faudrait qu'ils soient jetés
dans une poubelle approprié parce que
sinon matériel médical et nos moments il
faudrait pas le même nommément la règle
c'est qu'il met dans un sac poubelle
fermée de cette poubelle pour que ce sac
nouvelles sont mis dans un autre sac
quand vous n'avez pas un conteneur
médicale ces règles ne sont pas
respectées
à l'école on enlève le masque et on la
croise
m carlos alberto brusa toute façon je
pense qu'avec le masque vous seriez trop
pour d'apnée vous
gilles verdez maître brusa j'ai une
question pour vous vous opposez la
liberté individuelle
un principe de précaution sanitaire
mondiale mais précisément si vous un
jour vous dites on ne sait pas si vous
un jour vous ne portez pas le masque à
l'extérieur et qu'on s'aperçoit que
finalement il ya des transmissions si
vous contaminer quelqu'un si vous étiez
positive ou contaminés quelqu'un qu'est
ce que vous diriez à ce moment là je le
regrette
j'ai fait une erreur c'est au nom de
cette erreur là que vous devez porter un
masque alors tu as we know gérard
gimenez je réponds tout de suite la
démonstration que le masque ce n'est pas
quelque chose de si graves séquelles et
sanctionner simplement le non port du
masque par une contravention de 135
euros
si on est logique et je suis quelqu'un
qui peut effectivement affectés de
manière dangereuse a pris ce n'est pas
une contravention de 4e classe
il faudrait quasiment que je sois
sanctionné par un délit de mise en
danger délibérée à ce qui n'est pas le
cas parce que une deuxième fois ses 135
euros
une troisième fois vous tombez dans un
délit qui n'est pas du tout la mise en
danger délibérée ça veut dire que là
aussi il faut être logique
le juriste qui aida nous parle en termes
de droits thermique si vous avez une
infraction qui est la mise en délibéré
ce sont jusqu'à trois ans de prison si
c'est une contravention 7 à 5 euros
ça veut dire que le non port du masque
ne présentent pas aux yeux du
législateur lui même un danger pour la
santé de manière à mettre en péril les
relations humaines
delvin c'est le juriste mais c'est pas
le médecin qui vous répond mais le jury
se trouvent deux le droit toujours la
possibilité de construire les
syllogismes qui ont la capacité de vous
faire réfléchir et aussi si bon sens
vient pas que des rennais qui a du bon
sens et qu'on va passer mais aimer mais
monsieur s'exprime alors d'abord il y
pas il faut pas mettre le masque il en
train de parler de droit de deux trucs
je suis désolé c'est criminel le dire ça
aujourd'hui et j'en ils sont perdus
quand vous dire ce qu'il faut aux gens
qu'il faudrait définir puis vite posé
pour que ça dure le moins longtemps
possible
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui sont
perdus qui n'y croient plus
demain samedi nous écouter vous regardez
vos dérives par ces dangereux et
d'apprendre à jardiner le docteur zucchi
fait même si le masque ne devait pas
protégés et même si on sait que c'est
pas bon de respirer le gaz carbonique
le truc c'est que le masque c'est
psychologique parce que si on ne met pas
le masque même dehors les gens ils vont
ils vont ressentir ce regain de liberté
et du coup ils ne vont même plus faire
les gestes barrière si on n'a pas le
masque à l'extérieur quand on rentre à
main j'ai oublié le masque même
qu'aujourd'hui quelques mois et moi la
première savez le maître mais pas de
masque parce que permettez-moi une
beauté qu'au bout de la rue j'ai envie
de l'avoir arrêté
m comment vous expliquer qu en
angleterre où il n'y avait pas de masse
et ont su n y avait pas de marins ça a
été une catastrophe absolue moment où
vous dites ça excusez moi mais moi
j'étais à stockholm le 18 décembre les
gens à bercy a pas de catastrophe ou les
masques ils sont conseillés n'en savait
que le taux de mortalité de la suède
pour parler comme ça catastrophique a
réussi à passer sous les 3 % en france
le taux de mortalité 5,5 alors comme ton
parfois même à dix on cherche madaras
être évités en s'accélérant je prie je
regarde je vous dis sur la vie on a une
croissance de 5 % de mortalité globale
que ce serait énorme
le taux de mortalité fait pas de
s'annoncer par rapport à la mortalité
globale entre m je suppose que vous
savez calculé 70 mille décès sur 70
millions d'habitants
non ça c'est la copine je vous parlais
du taux de mortalité globale de la
commune
alors ils ont fermé ces mots des mots
durs chose chère madame
et aujourd'hui le porter mais ça les
arrange pas peut-être vous rappeler tout
simplement qu'on attend de ce massacre
et pour 70 mille morts alors que tout
laissait un énorme
nous avons 150 mille morts de cancer 690
me
deux personnes qui ont des mavericks
card parce que la priorité complètement
oublié aujourd'hui on attribue des morts
à la coupe de nos vies nous sommes tous
les sens et les membres plus anciens
aujourd'hui oui à 47% non à 51 ans est
donc très très partagés à minorer on vit
tous actuellement monsieur nana
on est dans une dichotomie on est dans
deux groupes qui ceux qui sont dans un
conflit permanent parce que je ne pense
pas qu'il faut être dans le conflit et
c'est ça qui est dommage parce que
effectivement on un clivage une pensée
et ceux qui ne sont pas de la pensée
devient des complotistes et c'est ça qui
est absurde latine alors qu'il ya
mieux il ya toujours la juste raison
gnagnagna qu il ya quand même une pensée
à avoir une pensée médicale ont dit vous
parliez tout à l'heure des autres morts
et c'est dramatique je comprends mais
quand il ya une cantine ni un mort qui
est un mort un dut quand il est une mort
qui est une mort un dû parce qu'on
n'aura pas pris toutes les mesures pour
éviter cette mort c'est là que c'est
dramatique
dommage c'est moi finalement finir
matinée là dessus le port du masque le
port du masque est un des outils que
l'on a ça n'est pas l'outil miracle
comme le vaccin n'est pas nous qui
miracle mais c'est un des outils qui
peut éventuellement prévenir de la
thrombine la phobie de touche des
personnes qui ont plus de quatre heures
quasiment